talking about resentment does that in
any way have you feeling resentful
towards your parents because it could
hold back you know that would be I would
I could so see how people would see that
and be like wow she's gonna be really
pissed off about that or whatever but
I'm not like at all just because I know
who my parents are yeah I know the
things they have and have not done I
know right The Witch Hunt when the
government wants someone they want
someone they're going to do whatever it
takes to make it look how they need it
to look and so really not at all like
there's no resentment whatsoever I love
that because at the end of the day they
are your parents and you know I know
I've heard you say that they've done so
much for you yeah and again people can
control this narrative and the media can
control the narrative and to be honest I
don't even know if I know the full story
but if somebody's listening that doesn't
know and we're not going headlines we're
not what how would you explain the
situation to them so everything started
back in 2012. okay which is crazy 11
years ago all of this started and it is
tax evasion bank for all all the things
that are you know if the government's
been going after in the recent years and
my dad had a former business partner who
we like to say you know what I guess he
hired someone that was smarter than him
um because he had stolen millions of
dollars from the company his business
partner yeah is that guy in jail no he
actually signed uh multiple immunity
deals with the government
and yeah so and that's the part that's
not in of course the the public yeah
they don't want that no no no they don't
they don't talk about how there was a
guy who signed multiple immunity deals
with the government and he lied to the
government they allowed him to you know
re-sign his immunity deal right and he's
the sole person that provided them all
of their evidence
and he said I did all these things but
they were at the instruction of Mr and
Miss Chrisley they knew about it and
never one time did the government during
trial our attorneys looked at the FBI
agent was like you know what you all
this evidence that you've submitted yeah
to the court
what have you done to get it
authenticated yeah and the FBI agent
just looked and was like
what are you asking and our attorney was
like you literally have Quantico like at
your fingertips right the FBI has every
tool right to verify that these emails
came from the email you say they came
from they have not been tampered with
they are but you say they are yeah and
you didn't do anything to verify that
these are 110 authentic
and they're like no no
and they said no they didn't do that so
that so that's the thing and that's why
it's we have filed you know we're filing
an appeal in March okay well this month
I guess and there's so many things that
in the public eye you know you see a
headline oh 36 million dollars of bank
fraud or you know tax evasion they
didn't put in the headlines how the IRS
had had five hundred thousand dollars
sitting in an account
at the IRS and never credit it to my
parents Social Security numbers oh my
gosh you had an IRS agent lying on the
stand you had so that's the thing is you
don't have these details that are out in
the public eye and when you're a
celebrity in the public eye they are
going to run with that all you have to
do is search for the press conference
after the guilty verdict came down
um and you had everyone at the ausa's
office you know IRS FBI and their exact
words were we hope this shows you that
no one is above the law including t uh
including celebrities and TV
personalities if they can't get away
with it neither can you so they're
making like an example making an example
and so you know because of that I will
never forget the moment sitting in that
courtroom a four-way trial
every single day and it took three days
for the verdict to come back yeah and
some of the questions that the jurors
asked were appalling to me really like
they didn't understand
filing taxes extensions you know the
indictment they were like so is the
indictment guilt
am I what no an indictment is not guilt
like that is not saying it interesting
it was just so sad how our system works
and
you know because of all that like I said
I remember I will never forget it's like
I'm now Law and Order used to be like my
favorite show to watch yeah now like a
cave and watch it really so like I feel
like it's such PTSD totally that comes
back yeah and I will never forget like
when the
when they stood up to read the verdicts
it was like guilty guilty guilty like
over and over and over again and I just
saw the look on my parents faces and
I just everything
like they were just in tears yeah and
we were because we were not expecting
that we were like there's no way like so
this so like in your opinion and there's
from everything you know they're not
guilty no no 100 and I hope that this
appeal will show those things yeah
foreign